i'll bring her a big toblerone i brought
you a big toblerone
you don't deserve this big toblerone
you know out of context this one clip
may seem like it makes no sense but
trust me when you see this in context it
makes even less [ __ ] sense so in some
crazy alternate universe this one guy
from some band decided he could make his
own show about an anime world seen
through the eyes of jaden smith
starring jaden smith with big names like
jude law
susan sarandon stephen fry and steve
buscemi providing some supporting roles
oh wait that was that was that was this
universe
this is what happens when a group of
millennial students more lit than snoop
dogg and 4
20 break into the netflix offices and
describe a random episode of anime to
some netflix
executive and the executive decides to
make an anime based on that description
alone and the executive is jaden smith
unbelievable now this is the part of the
video where i'm supposed to tell you
about neo yokyo but um
[Music]
i don't get it how did you know the
hellenists were gonna kill me
i had a dream that a toblerone was in
trouble and that
toblerone was you neo yokyo is a netflix
exclusive
that showcases the life of kaz a walking
talking personification of jaden smith's
twitter account starring
jaden smith featuring jaden smith's
voice acting
i'm not obsessed with clothes i'm just
an elegant man of taste
it chronicles kaza's adventure in the
100 real anime city of san fran tokyo
los angeles
in the future independent weeaboo state
of japarica
i just made that up right now but i
wouldn't be surprised if that was
actually true he exercises demons fights
to become the number one bachelor
becomes a communist driver and flies
around on his mecha butler
uh what else a demon possessed my field
tucky ball
oh for [ __ ] sake wait is this really
an anime
nah it's gotta be an anime look there's
runmer there's sailor moon who even
knows anymore
i mean was that thing i said literally
three videos ago if anime were to
properly become mainstream in the future
i believe netflix will have a major part
to play
we did this this is what we wanted
oh god what have we done i mean hey
who's this guy looks japanese maybe he's
worked on anime before probably nothing
i've ever heard of must be a nobody
studio dean production ig
never heard of them did i make anime or
something must be some small studio that
i've done nothing
but to be fair i think it was mostly
animated by some korean studio i
i don't know there's not much
information about the production details
of this so you can just go ahead and
take it down our anime just just take it
down
we didn't want this just give us shelter
but take this down take it take it take
this
take this down i had a full-on
existential crisis trying to figure out
exactly just how this thing exists
i mean what is this show what is it
you have a production with the voice
talents of jude law susan sarandon steve
buscemi and stephen fry
in something that may or may not be an
anime and this is the way they mark
their introduction to the medium
what in the name of shakespeare's ass is
going on here
that's a very very good question first
of all let's look at these character
designs they look like they're ripped
from some kid's middle school deviantart
project and the animation is not much
better looking like it came out of a mid
2000s anime and
i'm not sure if that's an insult to mid
2000's anime erika 7 came out in mid
2000's
filmetto alchemist came out in mid
2000's hell
i think even lavina had smoother
animation but you know it's not just
about the aesthetics which can be saved
by equally good writing
and plot oh archangelo what do you live
here
i wish i lived here me too
the writing boils down to this can you
appreciate the enlightened knowledge
that can be found on jayden smith's
twitter in such tweets as
how can mirrors be real if our eyes
aren't real you can discover everything
you need to know
by looking at your hands and most trees
are blue well good because this show
plays out like scrolling through his
twitter feed nothing makes sense
jude law why are you a mecha butler why
do people care about who's the number
one bachelor
did someone actually write an action in
the script that
reads vapes menacingly and hey while
we're at it why not tackle some hot
topics like gender politics capitalistic
ideals and communism
she seems like a bit of a nut have some
sympathy sir she's from the soviet union
it is a social phenomenon in japan that
is isolated up to a million young people
it's known as hikikomori i'm hikiko mori
now
now i gotta say though it's really good
to see western creators also tackling
real social issues that are prevalent
abroad hikiko mori hikikomori
and i mean the first step is always is
just using their word enough time so
one day they'll hopefully figure out
what it means this is not even
mentioning the most
gaudy in your face product placements
that are just insulting for anyone
watching it
so it's really lucky that i have the
cool refreshing taste of heineken to get
me through these troubling times
far less crowded than today that wasn't
a dig at their product placement i just
really like beer because this show
turned me into a raging alcoholic i keep
thinking that any moment i wake up and
realize that this was just some weird
dream birth
nope i mean there's no it's uh it's it's
six episodes yeah it's uh it's it's
still on netflix
it's not a dream if you're going to
watch it i recommend watching it while
intoxicated but don't worry if you can't
because after you watch it you'll walk
out feeling intoxicated either way
this is the worst piece of garbage to
ever come out and you should save
yourself a few hours of your life by
avoiding it like the plague
[Music]
is what i would be saying until about
three episodes in i had an epiphany
within this convoluted mess of a
production
i was having a good time i was
laughing it was entertaining it had the
same rhythm
jump cuts awkward delivery and comedic
timing you'd see in something in kin of
an abridged series oh thoughtful honey
the snacks are ready guys i gotta go
snacks are ready and then it hit me this
is comedy genius this is the final form
of anime it is an abridged series for an
anime that only exists
in jaden smith's mind forget what i said
about the netflix executives it's urza
koenig waking up one day and thinking to
himself
you know what i feel like making the
most expensive meme that's
ever been made it's so absurdly over the
top with perfect material that is just
rife with the best and worst of meme
culture today all it's missing is
someone dabbing with a fidget spinner
and a fedora and it'll be complete wait
hold on a second
charles who's calling it's aunt agatha
sir
put her through audio only
[Music]
i said audio only this isn't just
bad animation the animation complements
the amateur comedic tone in the opposite
way that niche show uses its animation
for its absurd comedy it's not bad
animation at all
it's sakuga jayden smith isn't just
talking [ __ ]
he's a philosopher way beyond our time
and his wise words here should be
listened to
yes it isn't neo yokyo it's neo wokio
when we think of iconic character tropes
in anime what do we see
tsunderes yanderes cuda rays but move
out the way boys because now is the era
of toblerone's erase you don't deserve
this
derry you don't deserve it yes this
is the hottest new waifu of the season
forget
ram forget [ __ ] megamin how can they
even hope to stand
up to the chewy milky triangular
sweetness of a toblerone bar
now i don't want to see just plain old
chocolate bars anymore posters
figurines [ __ ] edible ducky macaroos
come on jay let's get on that [ __ ]
overall i give neo yokyo nine dabs
out of ten right up there with ghost
stories but just shy of the absolute
masterpieces like the bible black dub
and the magnum opus of them all
ghazi's win damn yamato takaruniko
and i ironically hope that there will be
a sequel
with shiloh buff in it
uh well that just happened hey guys hope
you enjoyed the video thank you very
much this month too
robert hanborg k must live basil lee
what patrick madsen and everyone else on
patreon for helping to support me for
this month and making this video
possible
not many updates today but i am back in
thailand now and i'm thinking about
doing a meet-up for now i've penciled in
the date off saturday the 14th of
october
just outside the bangkok animate in the
mbk center at
around 2 p.m so if you're in the bangkok
area feel free to come say hi i've also
made a facebook event in the description
just in case any last minute changes
happen
also i can just get an idea of numbers
because i really don't know how many of
you guys are in bangkok
anyway that's it from me i've been
giggling and i'll see you all
next time